ERIK KAY: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the session, Chrome
Apps State of The Nation.
My name is Erik Kay.
I'm an engineering director at
Google, and just a quick
reminder upfront, before
we dive in.
We're really interested in
getting your feedback on how
each of these talks are going.
You can use either the I/O app
to rate the session and give
us feedback, or use
the QR code in the
back to do a rating.
So first off, what is
this talk all about?
It's about Chrome
packaged apps.
This is the way to build native
quality applications
using the Chrome runtime.
Let's see.
So, how many of you were here
at last year's talk, when we
first gave a preview for
what Chrome packaged
apps were all about?
All right, good.
Thanks for coming back.
For the rest of you, let me give
you a little bit of an
overview of what Chrome
packaged apps are.
So the idea here is that people
want to be able to
build native quality desktop
applications using web
technology.
Using web technology.
HTML, JavaScript, CSS.
They would like, though, at the
same time, to not give up
all the capabilities
they're used to.
Access to the hardware, access
to the operating system.
They'd like to look and act,
behave as peers for the
desktop counterparts.
And so that's what we've built
with Chrome packaged apps.
And I'm going to talk in a lot
more detail about what each of
these aspects are, but
that's sort of
the idea in a nutshell.
Now last year, as I said, we
gave a sneak peek of where we
were at with packaged apps.
Showed you how these apps were
immersive, how they ran
outside of the browser, and
allowed for customizable UI.
Full control over
all the windows.
How they interacted with the
hardware and operating system
capabilities, and how they were
offline enabled by default.
So after that, we put it
available behind a flag over
the summer.
We started shipping a few
default packaged apps in
Chrome OS this fall.
We had a few hackathons,
I hope a few of
you made it to that.
If not, there's more
hackathons coming.
Keep an eye out for those
in your local area.
We had a developer preview
turned on in February, so you
could start uploading your
packaged apps to the store.
And just the other week, we
enabled our consumer preview,
which means anyone at the dev
channel can now go to the web
store and see all the packaged
apps that have
been uploaded there.
And in our next release, Chrome
29, we're looking to
have a full consumer launch.
So let me dive in a bit about
each of the properties that we
have for Chrome packaged apps.
So first off, I said
they're inverses.
So what does that
mean, exactly?
Well, it could mean a couple
of different things.
For example, it could
mean something like
this YouTube app.
Now, this is the full experience
that you see maybe
on your TV, or on
the PlayStation.
But all custom UI full
screen immersive, so
nothing in the way.
But immersive just have
to mean that.
Doesn't have to mean
full screen.
It might mean that it's just
part of the operating system.
It's taking advantage of
different features of the
operating system.
So for example, this
presentation that I've got
going up here is actually
is actually an app.
It's a packaged app, and I've
got it, no title bar, I've got
it glued to the side
of the screen.
I've got it, no UI widgets, just
full edge to edge control
under my [? power. ?]
And further, I even have it
integrating with the OS in an
interesting way.
I put up a rich notification
here showing how I'm doing
this presentation on a Pixel.
I hope you all enjoy that, and
can play with some of these
things like I am here.
The rich notifications that you
can deliver there are a
relatively recent API that we
rolled out, that mirror the
kind of things, notifications
that you're used
to doing with Android.
In fact, we're trying to make
them parallel in most ways.
So these apps are
very capable.
And what I mean by capable is
that they can have access to
the underlying operating
system primitives.
They can do things like
access TCP/IP sockets.
They can access your hardware.
So for example, let me just
pull up a couple here.
Here's one that's built into
Chrome OS, and it's like a
simple camera app that's
talking to your webcam.
Notice it just looks and acts
like a native application,
does everything you'd expect.
Here's one that maybe the techie
crowd would appreciate
here, is as developers, this
is an IRC app, a chatroom
application where developers
hang out.
This is the Blink chat room
where the Blink developers all
hang out and talk about
the things that
are going on there.
In order to implement this, you
have to use raw socket,
TCP/IP to talk to it again.
This just looks like a
standalone native desktop app.
That's because the runtime
enables that.
I've got another application
here that I can't give you the
full demo of, because I left
a memory card away.
But this is the G+ photos
application that basically
allows you to automatically
upload photos that when you
plug in a memory card or attach
your camera, if you
just attach it, you
can curate it.
This is part of the overall
G+ photos experience.
So, offline.
So Chrome packaged apps are
offline enabled by default.
So what do I mean by offline?
First let's define terms.
On one end, offline can mean
I have no network of all.
I'm not connected
to the internet.
I'm on an airplane, I'm in
the desert, whatever.
But really, the more common
case is I've got
a really bad network.
It's unreliable, it's
slow, it's flaky.
I think a few of you are
experiencing that right now.
Maybe even the servers
are down.
Maybe the internet, your net
connection is fine, but the
particular server you're talking
to is timing out, or
having some trouble.
Native apps don't really have
a huge problem with this,
because all their code is
already down on the client and
already running.
So if they can't talk to their
server, all it means is they
couldn't get some
of their data.
They can recover.
They can detect that.
The web has had some weaknesses
on this front,
where because we mix code and
data together in HTML, it
means that if you have a network
outage as code is
coming down, well, you have half
your page there, and your
page isn't functional.
And that's why we have reload
buttons in browsers because,
how many times do you
hit Reload a day?
Invariably there are errors.
You have to hit refresh, or
hit back to fix that.
But your desktop app doesn't
have a Reload button, so we
need to make these apps work
offline by default.
And the way we do that is by
having the code down on the
device ahead of time, so that
it's always there, always
ready to go, and enforcing
the separation
between code and data.
Let me give you a quick
example of this.
So here's an app called "Google
Keep." Maybe a few of
you have already
tried this out.
Really nicely done packaged app,
and what you can see here
is that it's basically
just a panel.
So again, it's immersive.
It's sort of a nice size.
You can put it off
to the side here.
It's just in this case,
I've just got a
simple to do item here.
You can have other
notes and photos.
But what I'm going to do is I'm
going to play with fire
here, and I'm going to tempt the
demo gods, and I'm going
to unplug the network.
OK, what happens?
So what you'll see here is
that it'll say that--
well, actually I need to turn
off the wi-fi, too, which is
actually working, which
shouldn't be.
Let's turn off the wi-fi.
OK.
So now you see that the
display changed.
It immediately detected that.
It says all notes are now saved
offline, and so what I
can do here is I can still, even
though it's offline, I
can mark something done,
I can delete an item.
I can add another item,
and it's offline.
And in fact, if I just then
reconnect this up, it'll
detect that, wake up again in a
second, and it says saving,
and it's all back in the
cloud automatically.
There's no errors, and all of
this really comes for free as
part of the package.
When you write a Chrome
packaged app,
it's offline by default.
It's also cloud enabled
by default.
So it's all fine and good to be
offline, but then you start
to lose some of the advantages
that you have on the web.
The web is cloud enabled by
default, but not offline
enabled by default.
Native apps tend to be offline
enabled by default, but not
cloud enabled by default.
We're trying to have a bit of
both, and the way we do that
is by providing a number of
useful APIs out of the box.
One of them is one that we
introduced last year, called
"Chrome Storage Sync." And what
that does is provide a
way to have simple key value
pairs stored reliably,
synchronized to your account.
No matter what machine you're
on, it they follow you around,
come with you.
And that's really useful for
things like settings,
configuration, state.
So imagine you set up your app
on one machine, you go to
another machine, now it's
all set up, ready to go.
Or that you're playing a game
and you're on level three, and
then you go to another machine,
and that one is on
level three now, too.
It's really useful for that
sort of simple state data.
But what if you need to
deal with larger data?
Well, recently we just announced
another API called
Chrome Sync file system, and the
sync file system API uses
your Drive account to store
documents, to store photos and
media files, and that
sort of thing.
It's really good at these large
chunk document types.
And again, automatically
works.
All you do is use the HTML5 file
system API, create your
files, save them into there,
and you as a developer, for
both of these API, you didn't
have to set up any cloud
infrastructure on your own.
You didn't have to set
up your own servers.
You didn't have to deal with
scalability concerns if your
app was a runaway success.
Because all the data is stored
in the user's account, not
your account, not
on your server.
So you don't have to worry
about all of that.
Now, there's a third type of
data that the observant among
you will notice I didn't talk
about, which is database or
transactional data.
And that's where you're getting
the more advanced use
cases, where it's really hard
to have a generic API that
addresses everybody's
concerns.
So you tend to have to write
most of that logic yourself.
However, we help you out
a bit there, too.
Just last week we announced
Google Cloud, we announced a--
sorry, a push messaging API,
which is sort of the mirror to
Google Cloud Messaging from
Android, again, in Chrome.
And allows you to push data
down to your device
automatically.
And the nice thing about this
is the reason why this helps
in that synchronization, that
database transactional
synchronization model is it
means that, again, your app
doesn't need to--
your app can always stay up
to sync in the background.
Because what could happen is
your server can say, OK,
something new happened.
A message gets sent into the
push messaging, and the Chrome
runtime will receive that
message, wake up your app, let
it run code, let it download
what it needs to do, and
again, you can handle the
synchronization logic yourself.
Now, I mentioned earlier
that we're using this
heavily for Chrome OS.
It's more than just as a
platform for third parties.
We use it ourselves for all
of the built in apps.
The camera app I showed you
earlier, that's a packaged app
that's built into Chrome OS.
Even the file manager that we
use to look at images and
videos, yep, that's a lovely
picture, and movies, inline,
all of that is done
as a packaged app.
Calculator, that's
all there, too.
All the little utilities and
things that make an OS an OS
are part of that.
Chrome packaged apps are also
cross platform by default.
Since you're building it with
HTML, JavaScript, CSS, and
it's built on top of the Chrome
runtime, your apps run
everywhere that the Chrome
runtime runs.
So for example, let's say that
you're 500 pixels, and you
wanted to write a desktop app
version of your website.
So you build the packaged app,
photos all sync offline.
You can browse them,
view them.
I'm using touch here to control
this and scroll around.
But this app that runs and
works exactly the same on
Windows, on Mac, on Chrome
OS, on Linux.
And when I say cross platform,
I also mean mobile.
And this is something we've
been working on since last
year, but probably many of
you haven't seen it yet.
Let me give you a sneak preview
of what it means to
run a Chrome packaged app
on my Android device.
Here's that same 500 pixels app
doing exactly what you'd
expect it to do.
Basically the same code, very
little needed to be modified
in order to bring that over.
So, how does that work?
Well, what we did is we started
contributing a year
ago to the Cordova project.
You may know it by
its commercial
name, which is PhoneGap.
Cordova, what it does is it
wraps up the native web view
on a platform around an
executable, and then runs the
HTML, JavaScript, CSS in
that local context.
It also allows you to have
native API bindings to it, and
what we've been contributing in
addition to contributing to
the overall quality of Cordova,
performance and
features, and modularity, and
that sort of thing, we've
contributed some modules that
provide a compatibility layer
for Chrome packaged apps.
So basically, you can build your
Chrome packaged app and
now target Cordova, and run your
same app with the same
APIs on iOS, on Android, and
other Cordova projects.
Thank you.
Thought a few of you
might like that.
So, speaking of development,
let's just talk about
development and what
that means.
Because it's HTML, JavaScript,
CSS, you get access to all the
same great developer tools
that you've been seeing
everybody use in all the
talks around here.
And again, you've probably heard
this before, but if you
haven't checked out the Chrome
Developer Tools in a while,
you should.
They're changing at
such a rapid rate.
They're improving, and they're
pretty amazing and powerful.
So for example, here I can look
at the full details of my
app, this presentation app,
inspect all the elements.
I can turn off, toggle
things, edit things.
In fact, I noticed something
embarrassing here.
Somebody pointed this out to
me, that maybe three gears
intermeshed together isn't
actually the best example of
productivity.
So let me just fix that here,
and I'll just move that off to
the side there.
So I think that's a better
looking thing.
Now, not only that, but again,
because it's web stuff, let me
just run another packed app
here, which is a simple code
editor that we've got up in
our GitHub repository.
A text editor that has full
syntax highlighting, and
everything you'd expect there.
And I'm going to find this slide
here that I'm looking at
right now, and you could see
that it's very simple.
It just has this
one text here.
But I'm going to make just
another little change.
Standard stuff.
And because this is
an app, just edit,
reload, and away we go.
So that's great.
You can build it, it works just
like you'd expect with
web technology.
Now you want to get that
app out there.
For those of you who have been
playing around with apps or
extensions, you know that the
way to do that is through the
Chrome Web Store.
Chrome Web Store is really
easy to get going.
What you do is you just package
all your files up, all
your source code up
in a zip file.
You upload it, you add a few
assets so it could show up in
the store properly.
You hit publish.
An hour later it's live, and
your users can start using it,
installing it, and whatever.
We've also been working on
a number of improvements.
Since last year, a number of you
may have noticed that we
made some pretty significant
changes to the
layout of the web store.
And these have been mostly
aimed at end users.
At things like discoverability,
and things
that keep users coming back,
to come looking for more.
And it's succeeded on that front
pretty significantly.
So we now have much higher
install rates and return rates
for users coming back,
and we think that's
a big win for you.
But we're not done there.
What you're seeing here on this
slide is just a sneak
preview of a more structured
layout, where we're going to,
rather than just having this
long, continuous wall, we're
going to have things grouped up
into some sections, so that
people can sort of see the
source where these things are
coming from.
And again, hopefully give them
more ways to explore
and find new items.
We're also spending a lot of
time working on your developer
pain points.
The things that you've told us
are making your life harder to
do within the web store.
So for example, one of the main
things we've heard is
that it's kind of a pain to
administer these things when
you're within your company.
And so we're adding group
administrative features.
So that means that you can
have a Google group, have
different members of that group,
and then they all can
access different aspects of the
management to the apps.
You can have your marketing
person access it, edit the
copy, your developer
uploads the code.
Your business person looks at
the numbers, and you don't
have to worry about who comes
and goes from your company and
how to manage that.
It's very simple.
We're also working on things
like incremental rollout, so
that you can do experiments.
If you've got a large number of
users, maybe you don't want
to have a new update go out
to all of your users
all at the same time.
So you can do a percent rollout,
see what the feedback
looks like from your early
users, and then scale it back
if there's a problem
that you discover.
And finally, for the native
client developers in the
crowd, we're also working on
making it so that the download
size for end users is smaller,
so they only download the
chunk of the CRX that they need
in order to run their
native client application.
So that should be a dramatic
improvement in download speed
and how long it takes them
to get up and running.
So, OK.
You can get it published.
Now you'd like to actually
make money.
I'm pretty sure that most of you
are here because you would
like your apps to be able
to make money, right?
And maybe there's some
hobbyists, but really, we want
to figure out how to
make this work.
And aside from upfront purchase,
which we've had in
the web store from the
beginning, we're also adding
in app purchase now.
And I'll give you just
a preview of
what this looks like.
Here I've got kind of a
contrived, I want to make it
buy a gold star here, so
I hover over this.
When I click on it, it just pops
up some Google Wallet UI.
If I wasn't signed in, it would
walk me through the sign
in process.
Again, you as a developer don't
need to write any of
this code, but if somebody is
already signed up, they just
click the Buy button, and it
takes a second or two.
And I'm going against
the debug server, so
it's a little slower.
But now it's done, and boom,
I've got a gold star.
And if it hadn't done it, it
would have given me a failure
message there.
Really simple to use.
Just drop in a little line of
JavaScript, and away you go.
We're really interested in
talking to you about some
other things on the monetization
front.
We've got a number of other
projects underway that we're
not ready to talk about quite
yet, but this is an area that
we're really going
to be focusing on
over the next 12 months.
So basically, Chrome packaged
apps are immersive, they've
got rich OS capabilities, they
are offline by default, and
cloud enabled by default
together.
And that's an important
combination.
They are cross platform.
You write your app
basically once.
It'll run across these
different platforms.
You'll be able to share a large
amount of the code as
you go, even to mobile.
And you get all the
great development
tools you're used to.
And my slide is a little
crunched here, but
distribution and monetization
come into play there as well.
So I'd like to walk you
through, now, a few
concrete use cases.
So we've just talked about what
Chrome packaged apps are,
but now who should use them?
Why would you use this over
some other native desktop
technology?
Well, one example
is Chrome OS.
And as you heard in the keynote,
Chrome OS continues
to grow rapidly.
We're still early days, but the
fact that we've been one
of the top sellers, top laptop
items in Amazon, we're doing
extremely well and expanding our
reach in retail and Best
Buy, and in international
circles, as you've seen
announcements that we're
expanding the number of
countries we cover.
Now is a great time that
you can step in and
sort of be the app.
If you go out into the Chrome
sandbox, for example, you can
see a video editing
application.
This is something people sort
of said, well, you can't
really do that on Chrome OS.
Well, yes you can.
With Chrome packaged apps, you
can do an offline capable,
full video editor.
Or maybe you've got an idea for
some diagramming software.
Well, you can be the first one
out there who builds that
diagramming software, and like
[? Gliffy ?] is, and again
they're out in the sandbox,
and now own that space.
You become the diagramming
software for Chrome OS by
doing that.
Now, I mentioned cross
platform before.
This is an important use case as
well, but I want to expound
on it a little bit, because the
main thing that is changed
over the last 10, 15 years in
this is it used to be that you
really only had to writ e
for one platform before.
You just had to write
for Windows.
But nowadays you have to write
for Windows, for Mac, for the
web, for two, three, four
mobile platforms, maybe.
And maybe even another
version of Windows.
Windows 8, you might need
a different version
of your app, right?
And each of these different
platforms that you're
targeting has a cost to it.
They're different
technologies.
You often have to have different
developer teams,
different areas of expertise.
Maybe you can't share
the code.
Maybe you can't keep
the apps in sync.
All of that is a cost, and
there's also hidden costs that
developers often forget
about upfront.
There's things like installers,
and auto updaters.
All the sort of guts that sort
of keep your app working and
get it out to your users, and
help make it all work.
Those are things that
we take care of.
You don't have to write an
installer ever again.
auto-updater ever again.
So another interesting use
case is device apps.
Now, what I mean by this is
these days, there's a lot of
interesting gadgets out there.
There's fitness equipment,
there's GPS connected watches,
there's things that are used
to sync music to my car.
Basically, there's this
rebirth, resurgence in
consumer electronics because
these devices are all now
getting internet connected.
Syncing data with my computer.
And what that means is that each
of these devices needs to
be able to actually talk to
my computer in some way.
They need to have some bit of
software that runs on the app.
And if you're one of the
developers that's writing one
of these things, you
now have a problem.
And again, it's this cross
platform problem, because you
have to go where
your users are.
So you have to write an app,
write maybe even a device
driver for each of these
different platforms.
What we provide is some APIs out
of the box that will allow
you to do USB, Bluetooth
in a cross platform way
from user land code.
And let me just show you a
really simple example of this.
This is a little thermal label
printer that you probably saw
a few of the people
downstairs using.
But this is something where I'm
connecting this up to a
Chrome OS device.
Now, this OS doesn't have a
device driver for this guy.
I didn't know about it at all
in advance, but we have a
little sample app that we wrote
here that is written
specifically for this.
And I'll just do this, and let
me also just, again, integrate
with the webcam, take a picture,
and I say print, and
the printer starts going
and talking.
And this was something that one
of our developers banged
out in an afternoon in one
of our hackathons.
So, anyway you can't really
see it very well there.
But again, all of that was done
without the OS having to
know about things in advance
installed from user [? land ?]
code.
Really easy.
Another interesting use case, if
you're a developer, you've
had to write a kiosk.
An application that needs be
full screen, locked down,
single purpose.
Think ATMs or airport ticket
buying things,
or reservation shores.
Or even at the front desk
here when you were
registering this morning.
This is a kiosk application,
and traditionally, kiosk
applications have been written
on old versions of Windows XP.
There's like, an industry there,
and you've probably all
laughed and seen the blue
screens of death on various
terminals around as
you've walked.
And I assure you, for the
developers who write that,
that's not funny.
It turns out that not only is
stability of the platform a
problem, but also
administration, pushing
updates is a big problem
for these things.
And I'm happy to announce that
today, we're rolling out kiosk
app functionality
in Chrome OS.
This means that you can use our
enterprise policies, our
dashboard to automatically push
out and deploy a kiosk
application to a Chrome OS
device and have it boot up and
be in that mode.
And because it's Chrome OS,
it will auto update
automatically.
Your app will auto update
It's all written in HTML
and JavaScript.
It's much easier to build
the debug test.
And in fact, as I've mentioned,
the kiosk app that
we're using downstairs is
using this technology.
It's worked pretty well.
I'll show you another one that
one of our partners out in the
sandbox is using.
This is from Pearson.
They do test taking.
So this is a student test, so
aiming at like, high school
students or something.
But they basically want to take
students in, put them in
front of a computer, have it be
locked down, just take the
test, get the result, and have
things go, and it starts
asking questions and all that.
So right now because I'm running
this sort of already
logged in, it's not really
fully in kiosk mode, but
you'll have to take my word for
it about what that would
look like, and that the user
wouldn't be able to
pop out like this.
OK.
Games.
Now, games is another
important use case.
We've spent a fair amount
of time looking at--
this one takes a little while
to start up, so I'll talk a
little bit over it.
So this is built using native
client technology.
With native client allows you
to do is use native code and
bring it to the web platform
basically with the same level
of security as JavaScript, but
the similar performance to
native code.
And this one's built using
the Unity engine.
It's a cute little game that's
in the web store now.
This is a little demo
here, which I
apparently have reset recently.
So anyway, you hop around
and you've got
multiple clones of yourself.
It's very cute.
I recommend trying it out, here
I can't really demo it
all the way, but you
could see it had a
few interesting features.
It could be full screen, you can
add things like mouse lock
for first person shooters,
or that sort of thing.
Integrate with the gamepad.
Again, do what you need to do
this as a game developer.
Another interesting use case,
again, something you can go
out and see first hand in the
Chrome sandbox on the third
floor is this idea of saying,
I've got a website, and I want
to make that website
even better.
And it looks like I need
to log in here.
Uh-oh.
Best laid plans here.
Well, you'll have to go check
it out, the sandbox.
The idea here is that basically,
take a website and
give it extra powers.
In this case, they made it
something that was offline,
that could sync in the
background, issues down, and
so that no matter where you
are, whether you have a
network or not, you always have
the latest content, and
it's always on your device
ready to go.
And it's a full screen,
immersive experience that you
can bookmark and share, and that
it remembers where you
were, and picks up where you
left off when you go from
machine to machine.
So, a bunch of interesting
use cases.
These are where we've been
getting a lot of the most
interest, but we think there's
more out there.
These are just a few of
the key examples.
So let me talk a little bit
about where we're going.
So I mentioned we're in consumer
preview now for
Windows and Chrome OS.
That's in Chrome 28.
If you're on the dev channel,
you can go to the web store,
download, play with some of the
apps that these developers
have been making.
We're going to do our full
consumer launch to Windows and
Chrome OS users in Chrome 29.
That's later this summer.
Mac and Linux support
will be coming soon.
Right now you can run it and
test it, but we don't have the
full OS integration for Mac
and Linux done quite yet.
That'll probably be in the
29 timeframe as well.
We're continuing to
work really hard
on Android and iOS.
It's pretty early on, even
though the demo I showed you
looked pretty good, we're not
quite at the stage where we
think every developer should go
rushing and give it a try.
But we're going to start
reaching out to early testers
soon, and we'll be talking at
the Cordova conference in
July, and we think we'll be
ready for wider use around
that timeframe.
So, another interesting use
case I didn't talk about,
because it's something we're
still working on and looking
to do is we want to make it
possible for people to build
developer tools on
this platform.
And you saw a few examples.
Yes, I want it, too.
So one of the big things we've
heard from Chrome OS users is
that they love the machines, but
they would love to be able
to do self hosted development
just on this machine.
As developers, we want to be
able to use the computers for
everything, right?
And because of the model we've
got where apps tend to be
sandboxed themselves, that means
that we have to figure
out how to make the apps be able
to share and communicate
with each other, as developer
tools often need to do.
So we're working on some
experimental new APIs.
You can look in our GitHub
repository for a sample app
that we're building that's sort
of an IDE for Chrome OS.
Monetization, I mentioned this
before, we've got a lot of
ideas on new things we're
going to do on the
monetization front.
New APIs.
These are both areas where you
could get involved with the
community and give us your
feedback about what you think
are our highest priorities
for you, the things
that you most need.
And of course, we're going to
continue to work on those core
concepts that Linus mentioned
in the keynote.
Speed, simplicity, security.
Polishing the platform, making
it faster, making it more
reliable and more secure.
So, thanks everybody
for coming.
I just want to give you a few
more pointers to information
where you can learn more.
We have a number of talks going
on about packaged apps.
Joe Marini is doing a talk on
Thursday, I believe, about how
to convert your app,
your website into a
Chrome packaged app.
We're doing a code lab
that [? Renato ?]
over here is going to actually
allow you to create a packaged
app from start to finish.
The guys behind the G+ photos
app that just gave you a brief
demo of are going to give you a
walk through of what it took
them to build a large, full
scale, grown packaged app with
real database synchronization
the cloud.
And you can always find
us up in the sandbox.
There's a bunch of app
developers up there that have
built cool things with this
technology already, and you
can learn from them about what
they like, and what they don't
like so far.
Of course, our documentation,
you can find us on G+.
We've got a great community
there, and Stack Overflow,
we're there answering
questions.
We've got a mailing list, and
even the developers are
hanging out on our IRC channel,
if you want to come
talk to devs directly.
So, thanks much, and I'll
take questions now.
Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Hello.
This sounds really cool for
developers, but I was
wondering if you could talk a
little bit about the user
experience.
You mentioned Google Wallet and
Google Drive account, and
a Google account.
And all those things, and I
know that, for example in
Germany, there's a lot of people
who are reluctant to
giving all of their
data to Google.
And I was just wondering, how
many things do I need to
install as a user?
How many things do I need to
sign up for, and how many
accounts do I need to merge into
one, and how much data am
I giving to Google and sharing
everywhere to be able to use
these apps?
ERIK KAY: So I mean, it
depends on the apps.
The apps don't have to be tied
to Google in particular, but
some will be, just like
some apps are
tied to other platforms.
So it's up to the developer
about what they want to do.
We do require that you have a
Google account to sign in, so
that we can take advantage of
some of the functionality with
sync and sync file system,
and that sort of thing.
So that we don't force you to
go through that sort of
process within each app,
we try to handle
it a central way.
But really, it's up to the app
about how much they want to do
on that front.
MALE SPEAKER: How about
the installation
process for the software?
ERIK KAY: Right, so
the installation--
so at that point, the only
thing you need to do is--
we handle that for you.
If you've got Chrome, it'll just
install automatically.
We're also working on ways to
have it, so even from other
browsers, you will just
install these
apps with one step.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: We're currently
using packaged apps with
WebRTC on like, Mac OS.
And it works great, so when you
port it over to Android or
to iOS, is WebRTC going
to follow with you?
And then also, if you just
talked about the messaging
components as well, so when you
take it into Android, does
it change the Chrome messaging
into Android Cloud Messaging,
and how does that all work?
ERIK KAY: Sure.
So those are all great
questions.
As I mentioned, we're
pretty early on
with the Cordova stuff.
But it's important for people
to know there are a few
limitations of Cordova stuff.
One is that we're dependent on
the web view on the platform
that we're on with this.
So if the platform doesn't,
like iOS currently doesn't
have WebRTC, it'll mean
that we won't
have it WebRTCed there.
Now, we're going to try to have
polyfills when possible
on some of the features,
but some of them are
so in depth to the--
MALE SPEAKER: Because Android
has WebRTC now.
ERIK KAY: What's that?
MALE SPEAKER: Android
has WebRTC now.
ERIK KAY: Yeah, so Android has
WebRTC now, so you would have
access to it there, but iOS
doesn't, for example.
But for the Chrome APIs in
specific, those are all things
that we provide bindings for,
and we'll provide bindings and
try to map them--
MALE SPEAKER: So basically
if it's in Chrome on the
operating system, you'll
support it in
the packaged app.
ERIK KAY: So if it's in the web
view, if it's in Chrome,
the Chrome dot star APIs, we'll
try to support it as
best we can and map it to
the native equivalent.
So if it's rich notifications,
we'll map the notifications to
whatever the system
can do there.
That sort of thing.
And when it's part of the web
platform, we're limited to
what the web view can
do on that platform.
MALE SPEAKER: So now as far as
the messaging components go,
if I use Chrome messaging and
you're in Android, will it
move the message to Android?
ERIK KAY: That's the idea,
although we don't have that
one together yet.
MALE SPEAKER: Got it.
OK, thank you very much.
ERIK KAY: No problem.
MALE SPEAKER: Hi.
I'm actually an Android
developer and student who got
interested in packaged apps when
his MacBook broke down in
the middle of the summer and
spent the semester using a
Chromebook.
I know you mentioned an IDE
for Chrome extensions in
Chrome OS, but have you guys
thought or talked at all to
the Android or other development
teams about making
tools for other platforms
for Chrome OS?
ERIK KAY: Oh, I see.
So you want to target Android?
Yes.
So in fact, one of our internal
guys has a prototype
version of ADB working on a
Chromebook that's building
using our socket and USB APIs.
So yeah, it's definitely
possible, and something we're
interested in.
Some of it's going to be
harder than others.
For example, bringing Java over
to Chrome OS is a little
more work, obviously.
But we think the with the
combination of native client
and web technologies, that
we can get pretty far.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, and one other
question is I know that
it can compile to JavaScript,
but how does Dart play into
the Chrome packaged apps?
I know it's made more for
application development.
ERIK KAY: It'll be the same as
the Chrome runtime anywhere.
So you could either today,
compile it down to JavaScript,
and we've got that working.
We've got a few examples even
up in our GitHub repo.
And I didn't have a link to
that there, but definitely
check out the GitHub
Chrome examples.
But when a VM, a Dart VM becomes
integrated in the
Chrome runtime, assuming that
happens, then we'll just get
that for free, and we'll have
Dart findings for all of our
APIs as well.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool. thank
you very much.
ERIK KAY: Yep.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I want to
ask you about the uploading
process for the web store, for
the Chrome packaged apps.
And actually, I am very
interested in socket API.
And I have that in the Firefox
OS [? cases ?]
are using TCP socket
or UDP socket.
They also checked the
packaged apps in a
detailed way by the human.
But I want to ask you that such
a human check process
will be applied.
For example, socket API is using
in the packaged apps.
ERIK KAY: So I think we should
follow up afterwards, because
I didn't catch all of it, but,
all of your questions.
But it sounded like you were
asking when humans get, the
human review process
kicks in versus
automated review process.
And for the apps APIs
in general,
no, it's all automated.
It's really, we only have
human manual review for
extensions that use [? NP API ?]
today.
MALE SPEAKER: Hi.
I come from China.
[INAUDIBLE], organizers, so I
noticed the Chromebooks for
Chian is only one IME.
So I personally, the IME can
make a packaged A-P-P. So I
can customize my special IME.
ERIK KAY: With the extension
API, you're saying?
MALE SPEAKER: IME.
Yes.
ERIK KAY: Yes, yes.
So, I mean, we have an extension
API for making your
own IMEs, and so that's
documented in the extensions
system right now.
I'm not an expert in that
particular one, but there's
probably some folks up and,
if you go up to the Chrome
sandbox area, we could probably
find somebody who
could help you out.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
MALE SPEAKER: So packaged app
has apps that seem to have
tons of additional
useful APIs.
Is the goal for these APIs
to become web standards?
ERIK KAY: So, It's
a great question.
It's something that we've been
talking to other browser
vendors about, and other
people who are
working in this space.
And we're actually really
excited about the possibility
of standardizing these.
Right now we think i
little bit early.
We've been interacting a little
bit with the other
folks, and sort of toying with
some of the ideas of like,
what could happen.
And we actually were part of
forming the sys apps working
group to see if that
made sense.
Like I said, it's still kind of
early on right now, because
each vendor is working towards
their own shipping product
yet, and we don't have any
forcing function that would
really require interoperability
to happen.
And I think that's where
standards come from.
Not by things we design in
committees up front and try to
get everybody to follow, but
really when you have multiple
implementations that want to
find a way to interoperate.
And so first we have to have
everybody ship what they're
working on, and then we'll
figure out how to start
pushing on the interoperability
thing.
But we're very interested in
that, and continuing to talk
to the other vendors about
it on a regular basis.
MALE SPEAKER: When you say
what we're waiting for
everybody to ship their own
version of packaged apps, are
you including the Windows 8
programming platform, which
takes also--
ERIK KAY: Yeah, exactly.
Windows 8 has essentially
already shipped, and Boot to
Gecko is close to shipping, and
[? Taizen ?] is close to
shipping their stuff.
And there's a number of others
that are out there.
And so we're just sort of
waiting for the forcing
functions to come that
will drive us towards
standardization.
So it looks like we're over
time, so I'll stick around
afterwards to answer a few more
questions, and then I'll
go up to the Chrome sandbox
area, and I'm happy to take
more questions from
folks there.
So, thanks much, everybody.